[Music]
hello everyone
my name is Sasha and I'm gonna jump
right in with this incredible story that
happened to me last week because I got
this email with a pretty incredible
offer and I read it several times it
just seems a little too good to be true
and apparently there's this guy who is
managing the bank account of the late
Muammar Gaddafi of Libya it has 20
million euro in it and apparently he can
get the money out and I can get half of
it if I just help him a little bit he
needs someone in Europe I just need to
send a little money in advance a few
hundred euro which is not insignificant
but he'll give me half the money and of
course this is a scam some of you were
already laughing and when I was two
centers and sin because if I give these
people the money I will never see any of
my money again I'll never hear from them
again and so you might ask like what
kind of idiots fall for scams like this
right most of you already knew when I
was a few sentences in death this was
going to be a scam and it is not just
obvious the very idea that someone was
would fall for it it's a bit of a joke
and so like when I started telling that
story did you already knew that this was
gonna be a joke but it turns how people
do actually fall for these scams and I
love more like it like the fishing and
fishing emails full of typos and the
reason this is funny
to some of us and that it's hard to
imagine like what kind of idiot would
fall for this is because we're failing
to be empathic with the kind of people
that use all the technology we made
today and the people that receive these
kind of scams today because these kind
of scams they are not for us they are
not for the people in this room they're
for people who are more vulnerable in
some way who are less tech-savvy [ __ ]
elderly who are lonely who have more
difficulty remembering warnings about
scams people who might create
interaction and attention more they are
much more likely to fall for this
and while these kind of people are
losing their money over this because
every day someone this morning someone
fell for the scam again it happens all
the time while they are being harmed to
us as people who actually make
technology that makes this possible they
are basically the punchline of a joke
and sometimes it makes me feel a little
bit like this about working in tech
programming has such massive power and
potential to change the world and as a
community we're squandering it showing
the rest of the world that we aren't
worthy of it I hate it and those are
very strong words I mostly don't feel
this negative and I am being very harsh
because you aren't personally
responsible for the scams like you
aren't part of the scam you didn't
intentionally create technology you
probably weren't even involved in MO
technology at all but when we design
products or conferences or communities
or do something with data it's not just
for ourselves but for other people as
well and the values that we design them
with set examples to others and have an
impact on other people which means that
we have a responsibility to be empathic
to other people's needs and situations
which may be very different from our own
which is very hard and we do it quite
poorly usually and these are also very
difficult problems that's not something
we can solve on our own but each of us
has a chance to make a difference and so
with this talk I want to show you some
of the why and the how so I jumped right
in at the start and most people here
don't know me so I quickly introduce
myself I am mostly a freelance Python
developer currently I'm doing projects
in Internet infrastructure management
but I also have done a lot of work with
web development with Django and a bunch
of other things I'm still involved with
the Django community I'm also organizer
of join Europe last year share culture
of the Django Software Foundation code
of conduct committee I am on the core
team of Rights the docs which is a
community centered around documentation
and communication we run five
conferences and have a slack with 5,000
people and
Ackman rule came from one of our
founders and also I do a bunch of other
things and the best we have ever been
insulted is when someone called me a
neoliberal emotional Crusader because I
cared about people's well-being
it's very contradictory this also
neoliberal emotional Crusader doesn't
really add up and also together with one
of my friends I run a project called
open-source happiness packets which is a
project where we basically try to get
people to say more nice things to each
other in open-source and to reach out to
people who you are grateful to who meant
something to you you can do it anonymous
if you prefer I have stickers I have
cards and so empathy as a feeling is
something that we already all know right
it's like you've experienced it many
times it's a normal part of the human
experience when you feel for someone in
pain physical or emotional or someone
who is yeah who's feeling a certain way
and you can sort of feel how they're
feeling if you have no empathy at all do
you have more complex problems than I
can fix in 45 minutes but for example if
a developer that you're working with
they've been staring at their screen
uninterrupted for an hour they're only
moving their fingers they have their
headphones on you if you're also a
developer probably know what that's like
like they're gonna be very focused this
is a poor time to interrupt them with
something that's not important right now
and it's also not something exact
because our perception of other people's
situation and their feelings their
emotions their sensitivities is
incredibly incomplete and inaccurate
which means we're going to make a lot of
errors even when we try our hardest but
to make it worse it's not just full of
error it is also full of error in a
particular direction because it is full
of bias because when we try to
understand someone else's situation or
imagine how things should be for someone
else we consider it from our own
perspective and we all have our own
experiences and memories and associated
feelings and emotions and this through
the experiences that we have ourselves
that it is easiest to relate to someone
else but it also means that in the
process
we introduce a lot of bias because how
we read the situation of others is
biased by our own situations and our our
own past and basically the larger the
difference between someone else's
experience and our own the easier it
becomes to make bad assumptions cost
confusion or even call serious harm to
people and if my example of working
focus with your headphones on is
familiar to you and your can say and
office environments then you might also
be familiar with people who disrupts you
anyways when you're being very focused
and you lose a lot of flow when people
do that and then people might think like
oh you know why do people do this like
like why don't they get it why don't
they understand and I'm focusing why are
salespeople such idiots right and which
they're not but I get that emotion from
people and of course it's it's it might
be obvious to you it is obvious to me
I've been through that experience that
is a normal part of my daily life but
for other people it may be a lot harder
because they're experienced in this
aspect is very different from you if
they don't have this kind of blocked
focus multi-hour work it is difficult
for them to realize and to understand
that how interruptive this can be and so
this causes a lot of frustration but the
people who do this kind of interruptions
they're also usually not malicious they
lack experiences that say I have and it
makes it harder for them to understand
why is this important it makes it harder
for them to empathize it makes it easier
for them to forget it takes them a lot
more effort then it would take another
developer to basically understand this
and follow it and and make it natural to
them and this issue goes also both ways
all the time and we're hurt by other
people who find it hard to understand
our situation but we do this to other
people all the times well like I would
be reluctant to teach new programmers to
like I would help them but I would be
careful doing like a programming course
for beginners they assuming they're
listening have a be decent experience
and so I feels would be harder for me to
understand
their situation I would it would be
easier for me to make false assumptions
it's not impossible but it would require
me more effort also this issue exists
just outside of Dec in many ways in our
society is there anyone here who does
not recognize this person there's one
person there's two people who don't I've
never actually done this talk in the
Netherlands before so usually people are
like who is this and so I'll explain for
the people who don't know this is a
yearly holiday we have in this country
this is sinter Klass he is depicted here
and he is by definition a white bearded
older man he rides a white horse on the
roofs of all the houses and his helpers
take gifts down the chimneys of the
houses to the children and all his
helpers look like this so you have this
white bearded dude and all of his
workers wear pitch black makeup often
with bright red lips golden earrings and
a lot of other things and this is
something I grew up with as a child I
grew up here and I was so like oh no
they're black because the soot in the
chimney which if you've ever been I've
never been a chimney but I don't think
you come out looking like this
and so also as a child it's like it's
never been associated with anything
racial or traditional stereotyping or
things like that but then again I'm
white I don't experience that and if you
live here you'll know that we've seen
much heavier protests against this in
recent years and to me it only makes
sense that this is a racist stereotype
because I listened to the people who
were actually affected which is not me
I listened to the people who said I'm a
black woman and I don't want to wear red
lipstick around December because people
will will say to me that I'm a threat to
peace because I'm black and I wear red
lipstick but sometimes people have
difficulty understanding um there's of
course the hardcore racists but there's
also people will say oh yeah but you
know we don't mean it in a racist way so
this should be fine and so like to me
like the link is obvious and also the
people who are most harmed by
this day they have spoken about this at
length and I trust them because this is
their lived experience but one of the
most important things here is that
intent isn't magic just because you
don't mean something in a bad way that
doesn't certainly make it better
it can explain behavior it is not excuse
it and it's a very relevant difference
when we deal with people in communities
when we deal with other people in any
context because there's a difference
between they Snee ineptness oblivious
and maliciousness there's a big gray
area also it's context dependent but the
distinction is useful looking for
example at this looking at this example
from a open source community IRC channel
where someone said hey folks do you
think it's safe to use third-party apps
to integrate with paypal and someone
else said yes unless they're from China
Russia or Nigeria
I don't consider racial stereotyping as
being racist and another person says he
would not be wrong to be suspicious
about it and I think this is a great
example of being malicious or at least
something that no reasonable person
could argue is a standard that we'd want
to have in a community it was also a
violation of the code of conduct in this
space and I just think this has really
messed up I don't believe any of these
people seriously thought that they were
acting in a inclusive welcoming way that
they were not being discriminatory I
believe they didn't care but I don't
believe they didn't know and these are
basic kinds people have called me a
neoliberal emotional crusader in the
past it's pretty much the same type that
you encounter and so another example is
this one from the PSF community mailing
list someone said I bet even Pro
developers have good intentions and
someone else said they are good at
hiding it and like imagine being a pro
developer and you're thinking of also
learning Python a lot of people learn
multiple languages or they're stuck with
certain names that they might not
personally like but there they do work
then this is really unwelcoming to see
that like the first thing somebody else
is bassy kind of insult your community I
also just still don't get the joke I've
done this talk 10 times at least and
every time people have I just don't see
it
but I don't think these people were like
intentionally attempting or or like if
basically like they weren't trying to
discriminate against purl developers
they were oblivious to the effect that
their Jo camp and the tariff language
they use had and of course like in ten
isn't magic doing something out of
ineptness doesn't make it okay it
doesn't necessarily make the harm that
it did go away but it's different from
being malicious it's why also when I do
code of Connect management's a a big
thing is that you have a range of
options it's like it's not you violate
the code of conduct you're banned from
the conference but often it's talk to
someone and say this is okay don't do
this again
speaking of code of conduct I do feel
very strongly about him and I'm a very
vocal advocate and my strong position is
basically this refusing to adopt a code
of conduct displays an appalling lack of
even the slightest interest or awareness
in making people feel safe or welcome in
your community basically if you can't be
bothered to write down that harassment
and exclusionary behavior and things
like that are not okay and if you don't
have a process to deal with that
you're basically permitting it you can
be actively inclusive and if you don't
you are being silently exclusionary and
because of my strong views sometimes I
end up in discussions with people and
sometimes they have a lot of skepticism
and it often comes down to two lines
along this comment RG is the code of
conduct is full of sexist and harassment
and gender that people really act as
savages before the last few years wave
of political correctness isn't be kind
be polite towards other people enough
people did not actually act as savages
before this wave of political
correctness and in an ideal world being
saying be kind be polite is enough but
usually want to explain people more and
tell them some of the stories that I've
encountered myself or that I've dealt
with as a code of conduct contacts then
they sort of start to understand
eventually it's just there's a whole
range of experiences that happens in
communities that they were unaware of
and I also found that there this took me
a long time to discover there
a fundamental aspects when I participate
in a community that they are usually
unaware of which underlies a lot of
their initial skepticism and it was so
obvious to me that I assumed everybody
already knew this and they were just
being [ __ ] and this is also a kind
of filler of empathy and it relates to
some of the examples of scams that I
raised earlier that it's also a failure
being empathic with people who are very
different from you often not because of
maliciousness but because it's hard and
it's something some of you might not
have noticed earlier which is that
things can be very different if you're
part of a minority or a marginalized
group in whether in a visible or
invisible way there's another binary
division but like I said understanding
people who are less like you did more
different they are from you the harder
is to understand them this disre portion
effects marginalized people and it has a
fundamental but easily overlooked role
in the way that we interact with each
other in our communities because our
empathy towards others our understanding
of others is so biased from our own
experiences and it means there are a lot
of experience that if you've never been
through them yourself they may seem very
alien to you and gives you a
fundamentally different interpretation
and projection even when you have good
intentions and this is not a binary
thing there are a lot of kinds of
merchandise and underrepresented and
minority groups also beyond to the ones
like we usually think of things like
gender and race but there are tons of
them I will mention some later there's
massive variation in people in them so
this is a vague statement and also
people in who are in some arsenite
troops are ma just as much as risk when
considering other people in other groups
and so one of the things is that
communities never exists in a vacuum
things that happen outside our community
are carried inside always like this is
not a we all have lives outside of this
we love experiences outside of this so
it means this effect happens even when
everyone inside the space is being nice
and for marginal groups things inside
communities aren't always great python
is pretty good
but outside things can be way worse in a
lot of ways for example here's a map and
all the countries in that consider me a
criminal and also orange in Russia this
talk would be considered illegal all the
countries in red I face execution in
dark nerd I face execution if I enter
them all the countries in lighter shades
its imprisonment which is because I'm
not straight and that simple fact is the
reason that they see I can go to all any
of these countries without facing
possible execution or torture or
imprisonment this is a very optimistic
map it's also a little out of date this
only looks at a narrow set of
regulations it doesn't check whether
people are actually safe it's also a
little out of date us is bright green
because there's for now still a same-sex
marriage but the vice president thinks
people like me should be tortured and
also Chechnya is in there as I think
like a light yellow but they actually
have concentration camps for people like
me now so like this is and and why am I
saying this I'll get to that in a bit
and also being a transfer and one of the
things that I've encountered while
transitioning things like using a
bathroom which no longer always becomes
an obvious choice and also in Europe
legislation around this pretty good
announced just like you pick and you
have the right to pick so enhance is
pretty good but even then you can get
weird responses from people for me
nowadays is fairly easy when I was more
in between it was a lot more complex I
haven't actually had any violence like
in this image but I've definitely had a
threatening behavior and this is exactly
the kind of thing that unless you've
been through experience it is a
completely alien idea that this is
something that people have to choose in
and that may cause them difficulty in
their daily life we'd be quite often
most of us so this is a new experience
every time for some people and so but if
you've not been a situation it's just a
very it's just something that never
occurs to you and so there are a lot of
groups that experience all kinds of
barriers in daily life that other people
simply don't think of it doesn't occur
to them that these things exist these
are two that affect me but there are a
lot more and this reflects inside our
communities and our products as well and
so you might wonder why am I telling you
this
why is it relevant because I think
there's actually a fair chance nobody in
this room thinks I should be executed or
tortured for sexuality or gender
identity I think that's a pretty safe
bet
but even if everyone is perfectly nice
it is not necessarily the same because
the experiences we all have in our lives
are things that don't just disappear
when you enter a conference it is not a
isolated space it's something that you
carry with you also things from other
tech spaces because not all spaces are
as nice as the binding community and I
can make it much harder for people to
feel welcomed or included or safe and
it's not just the classic groups we
think of when we say martinized groups
but also think of someone who's had a
history with abuse for them meeting a
lot of strangers and sitting close to
them with each other in a room can be a
very difficult thing to do even though
those people are all being perfectly
nice and they haven't actually done
anything so there are a lot of different
different people that this affects and I
so tweet reasoning that captured this
well it is bit dark there is nothing
worse than being able to hear the hate
in your own head before anyone has had a
chance to speak when you can't escape it
when everyone around you is being nice
because it's everywhere that's really
dark I personally don't feel as strongly
but I'm also very lucky in a lot of ways
compared to a lot of other people in my
demographic but it's I feel this does
show sometimes to make everyone feel
included we need to go beyond like oh
you're not being actively harassed at
our conference it means going beyond
it's like oh we'll be nice to people
it means winning people's trust even
after they've had other bad experiences
sonic Bryant says if you're being nice
to Aaron that's really good and keep
doing that but it doesn't mean we're
done and it applies to me as much as any
of you because I
might be a member of some groups but
there are also a lot of groups for which
in which I have less understanding and
don't share their experiences so I'm
just as much at risk of bias
I need also issues that there are not
something that you can just opt out of
it's about situation when comes to see
they range from marginalized people
specifically or there's people who are
different from us in some way I've heard
people argue that they just want to
focus on coding and all the rest is a
bit of nonsense but if me and my friends
want to fix the communities then that's
fine we can do it but there's no such
separation because everyone here is part
of how other people feel in community
everyone here makes things that affect
the lives of other people and so every
single interaction that we have matters
everything adds together but the impact
isn't just limited to our community and
our social interactions it carries over
in the things we make as developers as
well the things we design are just as
much affected and they also set examples
of values to others and therefore I
think it's essential that we have to
strive for diversity and inclusivity in
every aspect if we know that the more
different someone is from us the harder
it is to understand them means that if
we build products with teams that are
all made of the same people we're going
to build things that empathize poorly
with people who are not the same as us
and I say every aspect because race and
gender are the obvious ones in tech that
we talk a lot about there's also things
like health status and income security
housing security education chance that
people have had whether people have
dependents like these are all things
that don't affect me at all I'm the most
privileged in all these categories and
so I really like this hiring approach
which is I'm pushing people to think
less about culture fit and more about
culture at how will a new hire add to
our culture because a lot of us
including myself as I just mentioned we
are in a lot of we have a lot of
privilege we are in luxurious positions
I don't have to worry about being able
to pay for food next week it's just
something that does not occur on my mind
although I would say they don't late
this morning so I to taxi I don't
actually know how much that cost
and I don't have to care if I don't do
it every day and so that is something
that a lot of people also in this
country they don't have these kind of
choices it's a continuous source of
worry I don't have to think of who will
take care of my children around here I
don't have to think about is this
wheelchair is this building sufficiently
wheelchair accessible and so having
diverse people on your teams in your
companies on the state of your
conference and listening to them gives
you perspectives that would never ever
have occurs to you otherwise and as it's
harder to understand people who are less
like you it's hard for me to understand
some people who do have these issues on
the other hand there is no way that I
would ever deliver a product that has
some kind of gender selection or
categorizing that is not inclusive of
everyone because it's something very
close to me I experience that all the
time and so that is something that I
know very well so that would never go
wrong it's something I do so if we
design products in a team with more
empathy we're more likely to create
things that only work for us and maybe
even bring harm to other people we might
not understand how they feel for others
and that can have a very serious impact
so this is the driveway of a farm in
Potvin Kansas in the US this is a toilet
and it was dumped there by uh none
stranger as some kind of vague threat
and the house in the back there has also
been searched for escaped convicts by
the FBI looking for evidence by text
collectors by ambulances looking for
suicidal people the police looking for
runaway children and a lot more and what
did these people do to deserve that
it turns out there's a geolocation
database called max mind and stay map IP
addresses to geographical locations for
things like advertising statistics and
for about 600 million addresses they
can't reach anything more than like we
know it's somewhere in the US we don't
know what state we don't know what city
but we're pretty sure this is somewhere
in the US and along with the along with
this they also gave 2g
go coordinates so you can plot them on a
map and and make pretty visualizations
and in this case the coordinates they
picked for somewhere in the US is the
center of the US and then a little
rounded which is Deb house in the back
and so someone a journalist can involved
who found out that this database was the
cost that every time the police would
look up one of these six and million
addresses it would say oh they live here
because that's the pointer that which
are on the map and so the journalist
asked the company about this max mind
about like you know buddy what do you
think about this and he said it didn't
occur to us that people would use the
database to attempt to locate people
down to a household level we've always
advertised it as determining location to
a city or zip code level and so
apparently didn't occur to them that if
you give the police a website and say
enter an IP address and it shows this
house that they will rate the house and
and actually they've been very lucky
that nobody died in that and yeah they
just didn't think about it and they
actually moved the market now it's now
in a lake so it's a lot safer for other
people I don't know whether it's any
more efficient but you know at least no
one will die over this I know there's
like tons of examples of this in tech
Apple health which you might know which
tracks sort of a central tracking on iOS
for launch for tracking healthcare data
and when it launched you could track
things like heart rate and weight which
are very often measured but also more
obscure things for a lot of us like
blood alcohol cholesterol and inhaler
use which many of us don't use but there
was some interesting metric missing
which is not yes also something that's a
bit more obscure a fact
a lot less obscure than inhaler used or
blood alcohol which was that the entire
team managed to forget that about half
the world menstruates at some point in
their life because it didn't allow you
to track this even though there were
already a dozen apps on the App Store
that could do this people have been
tracking their menstrual cycles for
longer than the phone has existed and so
it took a year for them to include this
distich which affects about half of the
entire population of the world and
security is also full of things like
this
if he does miss threats later to local
access or knowing a victim's password
spend 15 minutes with any divorce
attorney in 2017 I don't imagine it's
much better now
and Social Security design is full of
assumptions about the scenarios that are
important and the scenarios that affects
me and the practice I make are very
different from those of other people and
it puts them in danger and there are
also assumptions about what happens when
security is compromised you may have
heard from some years ago about Ashley
Madison a dating site marketed to people
who want to cheat on their partner in
2015
232 million accounts were breached and
most of the data was leaked publicly and
your first stop ends there was
definitely mine at the time also loves
the media it's like you know those
people kind of deserve it for deceiving
their partner it's like I don't care if
you're monogamous or not but don't lie
to your partner about it don't hide it
from them that's unethical to me but
this was the group the site was marketed
to but it was used in general as a
discreet site for finding partners by
people in all sorts of situations people
in abusive relationships who could face
very serious danger if their name leaked
out on that list and also it was used by
gay people in countries where just a man
looking for another man is punishable by
imprisonment torture and death and so
suddenly there was about lists of a
thousand people who were presumably gay
who were now in serious danger because
their names were now available to anyone
and also in countries where this was
very dangerous and so this like it
seemed like initially it seems like not
so bad but when you think about how much
harm potentially has to happen like we
don't know how many of these people were
actually imprisoned because yeah that's
not accessible data and I encounter a
lot of products that don't really think
about trans people of course especially
when people change their legal name and
gender everything just sort of goes
crazy
I had one um and they had on their
website a form where you could change
your name and change her gender so I did
that and I click yes it was like behind
looking
and then they said they sent me an email
few days later and they said you and
have you informed us of your new name
however it is not possible to change
this we have not processed your request
so they had an actual form on it for me
to change my name and yeah and then they
said no no you can actually do that we
have this form that doesn't work like
someone actually mailed me by hand to
say that I still have actually caught up
with all the places where I need to
change it for this one I just ended up
canceling the insurance I did that to a
bunch of things like changing my name
with you was so hard I don't actually
need you so I can cancel it was like a
good clean up in a few guys I've also
had to threaten with TV PR which really
helps because when you say gdpr
everybody gets terrified and under gdpr
you have a rights to ratification of
your of your details but also this is
easier for me because it was easy for me
to update my legal name it worldwide
this is very difficult for some people -
almost impossible and so systems also
need to account for that that someone
may have a legal name which is different
from the name they use in their daily
life which means also a conference that
requires an ID card when you check-in is
not accessible to trans people because
their badge might be different from
their ID card and so these kind of
things need to be taken into account and
I also really like this diagram from
Microsoft the image here in the bottom
is a bit weird I don't know what that's
supposed to mean with accent but it
shows that many of the situations that
we consider fairly rare are actually
very common if you consider them in
different contexts so people who only
have one arm don't seem to be so common
I very rarely encounter people who only
have one arm but someone who has a
temporary injury also only has the use
of one arm and then of course there's
people who have only use of one arm at
the time because they're doing something
else with their other arm
and in the same way if you make
something accessible to deaf people
you're also making it more accessible to
someone who is in a loud environment or
has a temporary ear infection and so it
means that when we make products
accessible to all kinds of different
people
accessibility also relates closely to
empathy and people who are different and
their experiences we're not just helping
the people with permanent disabilities
that are people might easily say like oh
there's a few of them we don't find a
better with them but no there's actually
tons of people who are temporarily in
the same situation we're making it
better for more people in more different
situations when we do things like
machine learning computers also turn out
to be incredibly efficient at
replicating the bias in the data we give
them and the biases we have in society
which is how you end up with face
detection that only detects white people
or cannot distinguish people of color
because nobody's ever tested that with
it because the entire team was white but
also all cases like analysis of criminal
data is heavily biased by existing
biases within the police for example and
so you might think you might try to
learn things from criminal data but
actually end up perpetuating bias and
increasing it or so differently
machine learning is like money
laundering for bias because you can say
like oh no no no we're not being sexist
the computer said so so and so it makes
it extra difficult it's made actually
difficult because as someone who works
on these kind of systems you don't have
to be actively biased you don't have to
do this on purpose you don't have to be
actively racist because there's already
systemic and institutional bias which
means it becomes very easy to perpetuate
this even when you don't mean to a lot
of bias is also present in employment
and hiring and I the wild ago there was
an article about a resume screening tool
so a company took looked at the resumes
of people who they hired entered it well
and those that did not do so well or
that they had to let go earlier and
basically use that to train a model and
then use that to judge incoming
applications and say is this person like
you to work here and do well and the
conclusion after an audit was after an
audit the resumes screening company
found the algorithm found two factors
most indicative of performance their
name was Jarrett
and they played high school lacrosse and
this is actually very probably because
this basically means the algorithm
biased words rich white men so they
already have that bias in their company
and so the algorithm just perpetuated it
also like in slightly more obscure terms
but like playing high school lacrosse is
not something it is income related and
so they basically trained an algorithm
to a benefit rich white men and then
said let me just see like you know the
computer said it surely it must be right
we trained it and so machine learning
requires a lot of careful work to
prevent these kind of biases and to look
at what what are you what are you
actually training on how do you prevent
bias and it basically continued the bias
of humans but people believe lesson bias
when a computer does it and so generally
a good question to ask is like how
people are going to abuse a product what
if this user is a victim of soaking then
like location data turns from a fun
gimmick into life threatening and so
like if you use location data it needs
to considers on Twitter for example I
can set my tweets to never ever show
location data like it's not possible for
me to post a tweet with location data so
let's say a good model I can just up
have completely there's those things
like accidentally outing someone for
their sexuality and perpetuating
existing bias because it's easy to fall
into this trap you don't have to have
bad intentions and there are so many
vulnerable groups where so easy for us
to cause harm accidentally and so also
role models and representation are very
important to the health of our community
because a big factor of people believing
they can do something is seeing someone
else do it and more that person is like
them the more they believe in it and
especially for people who have always
been told they don't belong here that's
not what they're supposed to do maybe
they've been through abuse can make it
much harder for them to believe in their
selves which is also why I'm open about
the things I talked before because
there's probably someone in this room to
whom that means a lot
and
yeah so but I can only be a tiny part in
that because for every person that can
be a role model and there's lots of
different kinds of role models beyond
and me other people will feel more
welcomed they feel more like they belong
and we need this to happen because if
we're going to build teams that
understand more different perspectives
we actually need these people in our
communities we need them to feel welcome
we need all these different kinds of
people that are currently poorly or less
represented so that we can can all hire
that culture ad and serve the culture
fit and one of the ways to make a big
impact we can't actually represent every
marson-knight group in every team
because there are so many different
kinds of you with so many different
experiences we can't represent them all
but it doesn't mean there's also an
opportunity for other people to
represent that and to say when you
design a product that to say like you
know we need to spend an hour on this
and then be accessible by screen readers
and it's actually very easy and here to
talk about it that I saw and in a way
you can also you have a chance to
amplify voices from the groups that we
often forget so in a way I'd like to
encourage you to make use of your
privilege as an opportunity because a
lot of us have privilege in some ways
and it can make it easier to be unaware
of things but it also gives you a lot of
power it means you get away with things
that other people can't for example I
don't have to worry about being fired by
my employer because I'm self-employed
and that means I can be louder and more
assertive about things in ways that
other people cannot afford to do I can
take more risk there is one very
important skill when you're doing that
which is to listen and so when it comes
to this subject there's always one thing
that always come that usually comes up I
mean with listen I mean listen to the
people that this actually affects that
who's lift experiences actually is so
don't think just because you thought a
lot about it you understand the
experience is better and there's one
reason that also has me staying quiet
most often which is that people don't
get beliefs that when someone says this
is very hurt
to me I don't feel welcome here because
of this this product is causing me harm
that people are just thought like well
you know it's I don't really see that I
don't really understand it I think that
happens maybe you call you ask for it
yourself with what you were doing and
this is very typical like it it happens
a lot that people basically deny the
experience you have as I saw a recent
DNA tweet if you don't hear about your
friends and colleagues experiences with
sexism chances are they don't think it's
safe to share them with you if you think
the explanation is rather they don't
experience sexism they are right to
think so it also means we need to make
it safe to ask for help to ask for
things we don't know because a lot of us
including me were reluctant in asking
for things we need yes last year I wrote
a talk which has a whole section about
this but it's not just me telling you
that it's okay to ask for help
it also means making a space where it
feels safe to do so that you won't be
ridiculed that he won't be taught like
that someone is dumb for not knowing
this for not understanding something for
needing more explanation if it relates
to feelings about you then people might
have told you you're oversensitive and
it's the offend that you shouldn't talk
about this and then it'll all go away
and makes it harder for people to speak
up the next time but it also means to
make a change you can start very small
like it doesn't always have to be a
massive project and I mentioned several
examples of people in this talk also who
might be more sensitive or vulnerable to
how we act that we often forget when we
make products when we design communities
for whom there's something about their
situation and makes it harder for many
of us to empathize and understand them
and harder for them to feel at home and
I share some of the things that can help
but I can only be a tiny part there's a
lot more stories to tell and there's
with every story that we learn we gain a
bit of empathy and so when I wrote the
first actually we have to talk I thought
I was going to do like a 10-point to-do
list of how to be more empathic and tech
which turns out not to be quite so
simple because people aren't so simple
and so what I've tried to do is not
just give you simple to-do list but
rather a lot of stories and ideas and
examples that inspire you to think more
about people who are different from you
and the impact that we have on them and
and the choices we make in that and it
can also be a very nice and warm feeling
right when you do this a few years ago I
wrote what was at the time voted best
transit app for iPhone after the
Netherlands I specifically made sure it
was accessible to people with visual
impairments which is free easy to do on
iPhone there was like a few percent of
development time and I ended up actually
talking on Twitter with several visually
impaired people who were using it back
when accessibility for chance it was
even lower and my app gave them a lot
more independence in traveling on their
own which wasn't actually why I wrote it
I was just like oh wow I'm writing this
let's just make it accessible with the
screen reader it wasn't really a big
thought and it was very nice to hear
that it had such an impact on these
people's lives just by spending a few
hours and I also hope it can be an
inspiration for the store can be an
inspiration for other people to share
your own stories because there's a lot
of different people here and some of you
have very different backgrounds then the
typical that we see in this environment
and sharing these kind of stories
opening ourselves up talking about our
emotions is a kind of vulnerability
which is often considered a bad word
it's considered a danger but it doesn't
always have to be true like this quote I
know that vulnerability is kind of the
core of shame and fear and our struggle
for worthiness but it is also the
birthplace of joy of creativity of
belonging and of love and that's I think
why vulnerability can also be so
powerful and sharing stories of all of
us who are who are different I'm not
trying to force you to be vulnerable set
your own boundaries it's not selfish to
help yourself before you help others but
essentially a lot of the things of this
talk come down to this I tell my
students when you get these jobs that
you have been so brilliant he trained
for just remember that your real job is
that if you are free you need to free
someone else if you have some power then
your job is to empower somebody else
because we all have power in this
we make things often just from our
imagination we don't really need
anything else we just imagine something
and make it happen which can affect the
lives from anywhere between hundreds to
millions or billions of people not so
often billions but a things like
substantial groups of people who all
have their own stories and backgrounds
and and ways in which we can harm them
or help them and it's up to us to take
responsibility for what we helped create
to make them not just right for
ourselves but also for the great variety
of people out there thank you very much
[Applause]